and now let's bring in new york
congresswoman claudia tenney uh thank
you for being here this morning
congresswoman we appreciate your time
can you start off telling us your
thoughts on what the president had to
say yesterday he certainly said a lot
yeah this is uh we're seeing an
authoritarian regime full on he has been
completely duplicitous remember there
was a time when he said we will make
sure that every american gets out of
afghanistan
and they will not be left there we will
not have mass man mandates and now the
president has gone back on those two
promises
uh that he is violated and i think i'm
hearing my phone was blowing up all day
yesterday from people who i would not
suspect would be as upset as others many
of them were democrats saying this is
just unacceptable
and people are really uh it's just an
outrage at this point that the president
would impose this when we have a you
know
it's just it's there's no science to
back uh this kind of move
is any of this federal overreach
ultimately going to prove to be in fact
reality or all the lawsuits that are
being brought against the president or
expected to be brought against the
president's executive orders going to
basically make this all null and void
well let's hope that there are plenty of
lawsuits that are going to be brought
and swiftly decided look i got
vaccinated
i think the vaccine has proven fairly
effective although we know that there
are people who
i know i have friends who have actually
picked up the virus after being
vaccinated so it isn't foolproof it
isn't going to prevent you from getting
the virus i think people have the right
to make their own decision uh this is
you know especially people in a
situation in my i've had two pregnant
women reach out to me
uh who have been terminated from their
positions because uh they were advised
by their doctor not to take the vaccine
uh until after the pregnancy and so
we're gonna also have a a worker crisis
because a lot of people as we're
struggling to get people to get back to
work
now we're going to have even a greater
crisis when people who do not want to
take the vaccine for medical reasons
aren't going to be returning to work and
this is going to be acutely a problem in
hospitals where we have seen hundreds
and hundreds of people who work in
hospitals protesting in my region
because of the vaccine mandate
and those who have already had the virus
and many other reasons that justify not
necessarily having to take the vaccine
but they're not prohibited from going to
work so we're going to see another
downturn in the economy potentially
congressman let's switch gears as we
reflect on the 20th anniversary of 911
what do you remember from that day
you know this is hard to believe it's 20
years uh but it's really a sad day and i
i always remember just uh
you know my son was only 10 years old
i remember actually the weirdest thing
is i was normally would be at work but i
had a dentist appointment
and i happened to be home just waiting
it out and i saw on the news that a
tower hit a plane and hit one of the
towers and everyone said oh a small
plane has crashed into the world trade
center and then it evolved into you know
just a diabolic horror that we all sat
and watched i actually went to the
dentist office and we were hubbled
around a very small tv that they had in
the back room i remember this is 20
years ago that what the technology that
the nice tvs we have today weren't
something you'd see in an office and i
would just remember all of us watching
in horror
um as it unfolded and the second plane
hit and the towers came down and you
know i still just remember just just the
[ __ ] of people running from 911 site
and also one of my
childhood friends was on the plane that
crashed in shanksville pennsylvania
particularly
difficult for our families
and before we let you go your son is a
united states marine we certainly thank
him for his service and he was deployed
to iraq to to fight this war on terror
and as you've seen how it's come to an
end uh and we are at the 20-year
anniversary mark tomorrow of the 9 11
attacks have you spoken to him about his
reflections
yeah he's actually just had his last
active duty day last week on the marine
corps i have to tell you something very
funny i i said to him i said geez i
think this is i feel sort of relieved
that
that you're moving to uh the reserve
ranks and you said you know this is one
of the reasons i would consider staying
in is because we need people to protect
america and keep us safe we need good
people serving our military and i was
just uh i was surprised to hear that but
uh
i'm grateful that he is uh you know a
person who cares deeply about our
country and his answer
uh to service was uh was for real and i
know there are there he's just one of of
millions who have answered the call to
serve the people who give ultimately end
up giving so much in the end and want to
give more and that's the hallmark of
those brave and honorable folks like
your son congresswoman claudia tenney
thank you very much thank
thank you so much hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now